miss Charles Moulton that is my
pseudonym
why don't you write Wonder Woman under
your real name because most Americans
have a low opinion of comic book writers
I was something else the person is most
happy when they are submissive to a
loving Authority I want to study her
she'll break your heart don't be jealous
I'm your wife my own Jason I think you
long for an unconventional life maybe I
just want her because you do
I think it's possible to love two people
at the same time why not what is normal
[Music]
the world were medic
[Music]
the world can't stop us is this what you
really want dr. Marston every issue of
Wonder Woman filled with violence
torture they don't masochism
this abnormal behavior and their comic
it's reckless a woman must not be told
how to use her freedom she must find out
for herself if you want to understand
the mind of a woman you can start with
that you are brilliant pure of heart
hilarious ferocious you are my life
where Norman has a secret identity for
example she has to hide her true self
from men's club
before would happen if Wonder Woman's
secret identity was revealed everything
would be awesome I wonder if you were
the one with a secret identity
[Music]
you